good
mexico civically
the world raid modes of eating and
groceries is this sign means the
search for them to stop there to be silence
because perhaps they heard a noise
emitted by some trapped person
context that was given to them after it
was also a sign of hope and that they
had to  keep working to
rescue more people
[Music]
you are fasting or a dentist and I am top the
moles are a rescue brigade
dedicated to the search for victims
trapped in collapsed structures in
haiti hifive mexico the head
valley tribes must be english wayne rooney
dental alive  group exposes
the balance to go snub in a clear way
the attention regimen we have
approximately 120 members for europe
the name of moles comes from the same
population that saw that there were people
who get into the rubble and that they looked like
moles from there they said it is that  these
men are names topo con topos
[Music]
firefighter
what makes us different is that we
are all volunteers not reci  We did not
pay for this and we have our
professions I am Pablo Dávila García I am an
architect and I am a mole
I am a data collector I am a nurse and
xavi is a mole and I am a mole and I am a mole and I am a mole and I
am a
mole seriously
[Music]
in both videos
the  world and heal the world he came to
find tweets under moments ago but
we have had the opportunity to go to
help different countries for example
nepal indonesia haiti countries of central america
we have supported their countries a lot
[Music] it
is hopeful to see more people who
care about others and want to
have knowledge about it
make up the rescue and that is what we
hope that more people will be infected with
that desire to help others
[Music]